compreso con nosotros desde Atlante la
vicepresidenta de panasport y de Centro
Caribe Sport Jimena Saldaña y esto nos
dijo sobre las vías para llegar a esta
paridad Pero por qué hay que recordar un
poco de la historia lo difícil que ha
sido la lucha la brecha que han abierto
varias mujeres a nombre de todas
nosotras y que se ha llegado a esta
paridad que vemos ahora yo creo que una
parte muy importante ha sido que pasamos
finalmente con el presidente Tomás a
nombre del comité olímpico internacional
pasamos de los Hechos de los dichos a
los hechos es decir se logró ya que
hubiera el mismo equipo en los mismos
equipos e inequidad de género
Simplemente porque se abrió nuevas
disciplinas para que fuera del mismo
número de hombres que de mujeres aparte
que para Tokio Se tomaron decisiones muy
importantes Como por ejemplo que el
hecho de que se portaran las banderas
por parte de un hombre y una mujer Es
decir de esta manera obligábamos a que
se respetara la universalidad que los
doscientos seis comités Olímpicos
estuvieron representados por un atleta
hombre y una atleta mujer al mismo
tiempo que pudieran desfilar y portar
sus banderas esto creo que fue un paso
trascendental porque a pesar de que las
mujeres han llegado clasificar han
buscado espacios y han luchado en
nuestros continentes y han llegado a
esas posiciones Pues no ha sido fácil
con Jimena Saldaña hablamos de logros
pero también de desafíos para las
mujeres en el deporte olímpico sin duda
es muy importante sobre todo fortalecer
los ciclos Olímpicos por ejemplo te
hablo en nuestro continente tenemos los
juegos centroamericanos y el Caribe
pasamos a Juegos Panamericanos y después
a Juegos Olímpicos nosotros tenemos como
dirigentes y comités Olímpicos que
empezar a reforzar la participación de
más mujeres que haya disciplinas también
femeninas en todos los deportes de
manera tal que podamos seguir apoyando
que se abran las puertas para que haya
más mujeres tenemos que empoderar a
nuestras niñas a nuestras jóvenes y a
nivel nacional que nuestros comités
Olímpicos sigan apoyando y no solo se
trata de las atletas debo de decirte que
hemos quedado atrás todavía le debemos
mucho por ejemplo al número de
entrenadoras mujeres a lo cual el comité
olímpico internacional acaba de poner
mayor énfasis haciendo una muy buena
plataforma para que haya mejor mejores
entrenadoras que las mujeres puedan
acceder a estos lugares nos falta por
ejemplo pues periodistas mujeres que
cubran los Juegos Olímpicos en fin creo
que nos falta mucho por hacer Incluso en
la dirigencia las dirigentes mujeres
tenemos que abrirnos más espacios para
llegar a donde se toman las decisiones y
realmente poder seguir abriendo la
brecha para no ser nunca las primeras
simplemente asegurarnos De no ser las